uh so our next speaker is a Norm chomon
from Tel Aviv University we'll talk
about cancer genomics
hi thank you for inviting me to speak in
this forum and session
this is a DNA actually this is part of
the human DNA
and we know with the advancements of
machines DNA sequencing machines
it's becoming easier faster and cheaper
history DNA and we can run whole genome
sequencing quite easily and very
frequently
I'm talking about Precision medicine we
want to give the right drug to the right
person at the right time
and what we could do is we could
sequence one DNA
and compare it to another one
you could do this to hundreds of
individuals and if we find the right
mutation and understand the phenotype we
could probably give the right drug to
the right person at the right time
we also combine RNA to it can we measure
RNA and find the right RNA to measure
and to fit the right drug
and what about taking a blood test and
looking at cell free DNA and trying to
fit the right drug
so I'm going to talk about these three
components and how we could use them for
potential Precision medicine we can run
along the DNA and we can identify
mRNA or protein coding genes and we
could look at non-coding genes
a loud group of non-coding genes are
called micro rnas these are short rnas
they float inside our cells and what
they can do is
bind the MRNA at the three prime and
translated region and shut off
expression so we have a lot of small RNA
molecules they bind the MRNA they shut
off expression
we can identify the site of binding so
we could predict the potential targets
of him of micro rnas as a list of mrnas
we had many labs around the world
sequence whole genome sequencing
and we do that together with Physicians
we do that with geneticists and
specialists in order to find point
mutations that can cause cause a disease
very often we look at the clinical cases
and we run along the DNA and we look for
the point mutation hopefully only one
point mutation that can cause a disease
but we get many many variants and we're
floating around these hundreds and
thousands of variants and looking for
the point mutation that can cause a
disease
so in order to sieve through this data
we use multiple filters and two very
simple filters
are one looking at the protein coding
genes so looking at exons missense and
nonsense mutations
and other filters will be prevalence in
the population so allyl frequency
so from the left hand side we look at
severity from the right hand side we
look at Rarity and we really want to
find very rare mutations that will
destroy the structure of the protein
but what if we look at the Red Dot and
not the black dot
what if we look at point mutations that
are in non-coding regions and are
prevalent in the population that have a
strong phenotype can we find those and
prove that a point mutation
could really have a strong phenotype
in order to do this we cross three data
sets
one of them
are microna binding sites so we have
these small rnas we know where they bind
if we look at conservation it's high
prevalence of binding and regulation we
could cross it with a list of
polymorphisms in the population and a
set of genes of Interest
so in the center here we will look at
polymorphisms in the population that
happen to land in a microrna binding
site in the non-coding region that might
affect gene expression and maybe the
phenotype as well
in order to apply this to a particular
disease we wanted to look at breast
cancer metastases so breast cancer is
very prevalent in the population most
treatments or drugs will affect the
primary tumor
and early detection becomes more
prevalent now with various screens
so this is what we did we took the data
and first of all we looked at genes
associated with breast cancer
and then we crossed it with potential
microrna binding sites on these genes
High Fidelity ones
so it's about half of them
then we looked at those with
polymorphisms on those sites on those
binding sites of micro rnas
and we looked at those associated with
the genontology of cytoskeleton
organization
when you have a primary tumor which is
really spread out with a cytoskeleton it
has to squeeze change its structure pass
for the bloodstream and then squeeze
again in a new site and reopen so it's a
major change for the cell moving from
one side to the other
we came up with 19 genes some of them
known to be Associated some of them not
we chose one of them Paladin which is
interesting
and I don't know if you heard of it we
haven't heard of it so we went and read
about it and we said it's possibly a
good candidate for several reasons
so Paladin is the a protein associated
with finger-like structures at the end
of the cells it allows movements
associated with actine cytoskeleton
really allows the movements of the cells
and it's associated with the protozoans
as well
it's interesting because Paladin in the
non-coding region in the three prime utr
has a polymorphism that happens to be a
binding site of two micro Nas the
micrones are labeled by numbers so mere
96 and 182
happened to land in the three Prime utr
on a polymorphism and this polymorphism
is very interesting because it's in
Ashkenazi Jewish for example It's
associated 50 with binding and
non-binding either a g or a c
in one particular population other
percentages in other populations
and the first thing we did is we proved
that the microne a binds there a point
mutation releases The Binding
we looked at cancer phenotype so you can
take the cell lines and now you could
run various assays this is the scratch
assay so you scratch the cells now you
increase the levels of the micrornas you
can see mere 182 mere 96 OE is over
expression
you have high levels of micrones low
levels of the genes we proved it and it
takes more time to close the gap and we
also saw that in two assays called The
Invasion and migration meaning that when
you upregulate the microrna it binds the
particular site on Paladin it down
regulates it and then you have less
cancer phenotypes
but this was in vitro then we took it in
Vivo and we generated three cell lines
breast cancer cell lines overexpressing
a control Mir 96 or 182 this is the
experiment on top so roughly after two
weeks we remove the primary tumor 20 20
days later we wanted to see whether
there's any metastatic sites
this is the primary tumor all of them
are the same size all of them are
colored red so we can follow the cells
you can see overexpressing the microrna
doesn't affect the primary tumor I want
to remind you we were screening for
metastatic sites
and this is now we removed the lungs we
wanted to see are there any metastatic
sites in the lungs 20 days after tumor
removal
on the top you can see the control and
you can see a Halo of red cells though
that the cells that metastasize from the
breast to the lungs
below that you can see over expression
there's one at artifact you can see that
a very bright dot but when we over
Express the tumor cells with the
micrornas we reduce the levels of
Paladin if it has The Binding site if it
doesn't have the binding site it
wouldn't affect it and we stop
metastasis to the lungs
now at this point this is actually
cheating con because none of the breast
cancer cells arrive to the body together
with the therapy so then we did a third
test and in this experiment we did
exactly the same you can see on top with
one difference the NP
two days before tumor removal we
injected nanoparticles
surrounded by the micrornas for small
release and a few other tricks for
example it was colored green so we can
follow it
so two days before tumor removal and
during the operation we inserted the
green material nanoparticles releasing
Mir 96 182 or a control here you can
just see the tumor in red you can see
the nanoparticles in green
and here as well these are additional
controls so no drug and with drug mean
actually CIS platin so we added another
drug
because we wanted to show that we might
be able to affect the primary tumor and
not only the secondary one but I want to
show you the results so
this is a CT image of a mouse
20 days after nanoparticle injection and
removal of the primary tumor so we are
releasing the micrornas short rnas we
checked the genotype to make sure that
it could bind the tumor cells in these
mice
and here every red arrow indicates a
metastatic size in the lung that derive
from the breast cancer these are the
controls you can see there's quite a few
metastatic sites and these are the
experiments
mu196 and 182 so zero to one metastatic
sites in the lungs 20 days later after
removal of the primary tumor when we
release these small rnas that could bind
the MRNA and shut off the expression
in order to show relevance to samples in
humans so this is Guilty By Association
this is just downloading the data and
looking for anti-correlation so there's
a high correlation between the two
micrornas meaning they work at the same
time and there's an anti-correlation
between the microrna and the gene
meaning inside the tumor in breast
cancer you can see an anti-correlation
between the two possibly associating one
regulating the other
and we also looked at Palatine levels
related to lymph node metastatic stage
meaning Paladin is high more metastatic
stages in the lymph nodes around the
breast cancer at least to some stage
and then we took a totally different
approach we took another study and over
here we use injecting the same cells the
breast cancer cell lines either directly
to the blood on top that's IV
or orthopedically orthotopically sorry
into the memory fat pad of the mouse so
here what we have is we have
orthotopically in the breast cancer or
memory fat pad where the cells have to
be released from the primary tumor
squeeze into the blood and squeeze to a
secondary site
or we have it directly to the blood so
this is a bonus cell it doesn't have to
be released from the primary tumor it's
injected straight into the blood
and we profiled metastatic sites in the
first model on top and in the second
model at the bottom and we asked what
are the molecular changes
that occur if we give a bonus cell that
doesn't have to be released from the
primary tumor and goes straight to the
blood
the profile the micrornas there and one
significant one the top one that was
down regulated was mirror 96.
so in order for a cell to be released
from the primary tumor
mere 96 has to go down decrease in
expression that means the genes mostly
Paladin can be upregulated which allows
it really to squeeze into the
bloodstream and move from one side to
the other
and then we prove that in vitro again
that we have the binary that we could
profile the DNA and the RNA we can see
The Binding we did that in vitro we also
have in Vivo experiments here where we
can see that with upregulation of Mir 96
you can have a difference and effect
here in first of all survival that's the
bottom right hand side and also you can
see the number of metastatic sites
in order to see some correlation into
human data again we looked at expression
levels of mere 96 and the various Gene
levels and you can see here down
regulation of beer 96 with increased
levels of cancer of the this
specifically was in the human breast
cancer
so the model we have is and we crossed a
lot of data now is looking at microrna
binding sites looking at polymorphisms
in three prime utr untranslated regions
and looking at sets of genes which are
relevant for our study we have the model
that we can first test it in vitro to
really confirm that the microna can bind
this untranslated region and one point
mutation can alleviate this binding and
upregulate the gene
we look at large data set to see that
there's relevance in humans that might
be relevance in human later on and we
have the model where we could test it we
can insert it into nanoparticles and
test it in animals to summarize this
part
we showed that Paladin is regulated by
Mir 96 and 182 now we have a set of
genes we have several genes that are
associated with these micro rnas we can
show that mirror 96 is a powerful
regulator in these sites of metastatic
breast cancer
we showed that one nucleotide change
in an untranslated region could really
have a significant significant phenotype
phenotypic effect in mice
and we're looking at both DNA and RNA so
if we know the sequence of DNA in the
three prime utr we can fit the right RNA
that could bind it we mentioned that
there's evading we mentioned that
particular point mutations can evade
this binding if we know the binding if
we sequence the DNA we know which RNA to
use in order to bind into it
and I also mentioned cell free DNA so
for selfie DNA I want to invite Das
volkov a graduate student in the lab to
continue this part
so thank you not thank you for the
opportunity to present some of my
ongoing research on self-read DNA and
cleanser genomics so software DNA are
DNA fragments that are released into the
bloodstream during cell death and in the
case of cancer patients that bear a
tumor also DNA fragments from the tumor
are reduced into the bloodstream our
ability to detect and to identify those
fragments that are associated with the
tumor can contribute to the development
of early detection methods and also to
assist in assessment of tumor burden and
tumor profiling in later stages of the
disease
there has been much discussion regarding
the differences that governs two groups
of software engineering right
and the most notable ones are
methylation patterns and fragment length
distribution
unfortunately in fragment omics and Next
Generation sequencing these two features
are somewhat lost
but we argue that we still have enough
information and enough features that can
separate that we can propose a method to
separate these two groups
so as of most of you are aware of in the
case of classification and Big Data
machine learning and especially deep
learning are a good means to offer
classification and to
offer some ways to divide subgroups when
Big Data is available so our task here
is pretty much a straightforward one we
want to build a deep learning based
model that wants an ngi sequence is
presented to it the model will know how
to classify it correctly as either of
tumor of or normal in origin
so we set forth in developing a
supervised deep learning model in order
to create the supervised part we need to
gain access we need to create two groups
for the training process for this we get
access to a cohort of 28 land
endocardinoma patients where for each
patient we have three separate whole
genome sequencing experiment
one for the German for the healthy
tissue second for the tumor tissue and
third a cell free DNA or genome
sequencing
by comparing the tumor DNA against the
healthy DNA we can locate all the
positions along the genome where a small
mutational change have occurred due to
the malignancy now that we have this
list of positions we can look at the
cell 3D DNA and extract all the
fragments that bear a mutation will
change associated with the malignancy
as the tumor fraction in the sulfur DNA
is roughly of one percent we can
randomly sample other fragments that
don't bear a mutational change and
create the second group of healthy
healthy sequences
our first assumption was that the the
main feature that will separate these
two group will be encoded in the
sequence so we resulted into NLP Auto
encoders and traditional means to uh
reveal sequence motifs but unfortunately
this this did not come up with any
meaningful separation this is not to say
that there isn't a sequence Motif it
just means that the way we collected our
training data set did not reveal this
kind of information
but there was one feature that kept on
Rising when we looked at the data and
this is the base quality along fragment
length
so when DNA is extracted either from
within cells it doesn't matter if it's
tumor or normal tissue then the base
qualities are relatively high but sulfur
DNA is intrinsically of lower quality
and when we plot these two groups side
by side a meaningful Gap arrivals this
gives us the hope that our model can
centralize around features that hold
information regarding the quality of the
of the bases
so due to the nature of our data we
decided to go with a relatively simple
approach but one that has two branches
the first branch is a convolutional
branch that holds information regarding
the sequence the base quality and the
relationship between the the sequence
and the reference genome and another
linear branch that holds general
information on the fragments including
position overall mapping quality and
length
so the results for this model show above
80
correct accuracy meaning our model was
able to to correctly classify our
sequences at 80 and also uh the area
under the curve for the iuc curve which
is a good measurement for deep learning
classification shows 88 making us
confident that this model works
lastly we wanted to offer some means of
explainability for our models so for the
convolutional part as I seen that I've
shown before the quality information is
the most predominant feature but for the
linear Branch we can perform a boosted
regression and then plot the shock value
which will give us some means of impact
of the features so even though we
correct it for the mismatches remember
we took sequences that have a mutational
change but it does have a mismatch so
even though we corrected to death we
still get the mismatches and the
alignment score to be a prominent or
important features which means the
cancer related
the tumor related sequences have more
variations in them
so this is an ongoing project we want to
collaborate with more hospitals and we
want to generalize it for more cancer
types but this gives us a promising
First Resource to show that we are able
to use fragment omics in the Next
Generation sequencing to perform
classification and detection of cancer
foreign
[Music]
this is just the
SE
this is just summarizing that we can
look at the DNA we can look at
non-coding regions and look at
polymorphism on mutations there fit the
right RNA levels in order to shut off
the expression based on those and see a
significant phenotype and eventually it
would be applicable in a hopefully in a
blood test where you don't have to take
the tumor but you could possibly look at
the profiling the DNA selfie DNA in the
blood in the plasma and then fit the
right RNA
based on these specific mutations even
if they're non-coding regions this is
the wonderful team performing the
experiments the most of the cancer
experiments were carried out by Avital
gilam
near Pilar and Daphne Vice class and
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
out of our own project periods right so
when you perform the sharp analysis if
you check whether they are robust in
front of different classifiers so you
use the XT boosted here but what happens
if you go to random four so do you get
quality of this the alignment the query
length that are the most important or
this is dependent
so I don't have a straight answer for
you yes but uh but what I was more
interested in just to get a notion that
my uh results have a biological uh sense
because as we know cancer is a phenomena
of the genome and if I can show that
there is more variation that cause this
differences than I know and this model
might be might be correct but I don't
think that other classifiers it's worth
checking but I don't think other
classifiers will reveal something else
and then you'll only feed the network
the Deep network with this information
so does it drop the performance
it's not it's also it's very governed by
the base quality and the quality and
messages
convergence so how how well do you think
your message will work for others
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry there was a question at the
back first okay
I have to say I'm very confused about
this observation that do you see
differences in base quality scores which
are
the technical [ __ ] of the instruments
and frequently Glory related to kind of
how
things the flows elbows loaded or
other problems I guess of
yeah hopefully the library and the
instrument
can you exclude the batch effect here I
mean this is this is very unexpected
yes we agree with you you want to
comment on that beyond that yeah this is
why we firstly went into sequence
related information this was our first
uh more interesting goal but kept on
seeing this information from the base
quality
made us realism what what can cause this
no what you're seeing here are two
groups
from the same sample it's not that it's
one group from one side or another group
from a different sample it's just the
way I divided the two pools so if it did
occur only based on the instrument then
these two groups would have been aligned
together so
we are asking is there some biological
effect that affects the technical
pickup or protocol or method that could
eventually
come out in this readout is there
something biological can affect the
proximal I mean but people have seen for
cell free DNA of cancer samples as if
they are slightly shorter that the
fragments are slightly shorter than the
the other ones and if you for some
reason right to elaborate you're running
earlier into the sequencing adapter and
you have more synchronized sequences
that this would impact your
your quality scores of the instrument
it would be very indirect readout of
that in this case I would say it would
be much better if you actually I don't
know did adapt the trimming and would be
looking at the actual sequencing length
but the read remaining reflex that we
made of the trimming
so as I'm trying to show here the you
know the lower left figure shows the the
length of the of the rate so of course
there is adaptive trimming and but the
differences between those two groups in
terms of length is not that obvious it
might be due to the way uh you know the
Next Generation sequencing works but you
do cut off the sequences you fragmented
so you lose some information regarding
them
let's talk about that okay
uh
for credit scores the quality has asked
key characters rather than
don't you lose the ordinal relationship
between the quality scores so everything
is important in the numbers yeah oh okay
it's just just for a presentation all
right
96 you can reduce the RNA of uh
to expect both to see some some other
transcripts
they have effects on other transcripts
we have two or three more proteins that
we are focusing now they are all in the
network or circles around the Paladin
we're now checking to see the
dimerization The Binding to actually
acting cytoskeleton itself does it
affect it or not so we are expanding
these Circles of Regulation yes
certainly am I even found a circuit
system yes
okay thank you